what's up everyone welcome back to the
supper suite at Tiff 2022 I have the
team behind fixation I already kind of
said this to you but oh my God the movie
Magic in this movie is something else I
just can't believe your production thank
you we love intensities so yes yeah I I
have a lot of intensity about the movie
and the movie itself is quite intense
we'll get into some specifics but
Mercedes I have to make you do this to
start because a lot of our viewers out
there will not know what fixation is
just yet can you give a brief synopsis
of removing Yeah so basically fixation
is about a young woman
um Dora who wakes up in this mental
institution and she doesn't know how she
got there and there's these odd doctors
and experience going on and then she
basically goes down the rabbit hole and
I'll just leave it at that to not give
anything else away we were prepared for
that yeah yeah I've been pitching it a
long time okay I'm very very impressed
so I have a lot of big burning questions
but one of the biggest of the bunch is
how did you select the song Always
Forever cause it got stuck in my head
and I went out and I bought it
immediately after the movie was over yes
that is the best compliment because we
wanted to like ingrain in the skulls of
people and just play over and over and
over success yes
um but the way that we found it is it's
a song that I've always loved because it
has this like very odd like hauntingness
to it that's also emotional and so
before we started we picked it out and
we're like can we get the rights of the
song to play literally 12 times in the
movie
um so we brought it in and then Maddie
and I like when we first started out we
were like this is how the dance goes
with this song it just became a part of
it how did you decide the specifics of
the dance was it was it just kind of
like free-flowing in the moment or was
there anything in particular you wanted
to capture through it yeah I mean like
um we looked at like a lot of different
types but um like Maddie I'll let you
talk to that too about like because a
lot of movements was things that you
embodied and brought out um we had a
really lovely choreographer named Enzo I
always forget Enzo's
Enzo Romero I'm the shittiest person
alive
um and he choreographed this beautiful
dance he's incredibly talented he was
also our sad photographer he's like
amazing so a lot of it was him but he
was very collaborative and I have like a
bit of a dance background so that was
fun for me because I got to be like yeah
I'm 13 again you know what I mean and I
love that I love to be a teenager still
um what was I going to say
I can't quite help you with that but I
can give you an excuse that we have
Festival brain we're buzzing and we're
excited right now I guarantee you I'm
also just like beaming looking at you
I really am explode live on camera not
Live recorded because remember we have
an editor I'm just happy happy to see
your face I needed it this morning I did
success I've always got you covered yeah
you did I want to come back to you
Mercedes wait can you can you tell us a
little bit about how some of your own
experiences inspired what we see in this
film and I hate asking a director for
like the intention and then like the
meaning behind them yeah but really like
the the impression you're hoping to make
on viewers out there because it can help
people reprocess some really difficult
human truths that they might go through
and they might not be able to do it
unless they had a fictional story to
experience it through yeah definitely so
I developed the story with um William
Frank the writer and Katrina kudlick
who's also a producer on it a couple
years ago and it kind of has a bit of
each of us in it and some of our own
stories and like for me personally
Tehachapi or Dora grew up is where I
grew up and so this very small town with
like very few people and I feel like
when you have very few people it's
easier to be manipulated because you
don't have anyone to bounce things off
of and so you don't know what's real or
not and it got to a point with me where
I started to record my conversations
because I was being told that what
happened didn't and so that was the only
way I was able to like keep track of
reality and so that's for myself but for
other people it's really sad but I feel
like every woman I know has had
experiences similar to this
um but we also wanted like the male and
female perspective so that's why we came
all together on this we're like what's
all parts of this I don't know if you
could see it but like the weight of what
you were just explaining like on my face
is I'm like yeah yeah to a degree not
maybe the same way but yeah I feel like
everybody goes through something of the
sorts at some point
Atticus sorry what how how to phrase a
question about your character I'll go
I'll go this route maybe although this
feels like it could tiptoe into spoilers
as well what would you say were some of
your biggest burning questions initially
after reading the script for Mercedes
burning oh geez burning questions
um I feel like the only one we really I
must have had for you was just kind of
the
how to properly go about exploring all
the different levels of this character
and every time we see him he's kind of a
new version
and just keeps exponentially evolving
and becoming like worse and worse and
worse and by worse I also mean like I
don't I think it's like this becomes
incredibly spoiler
yeah but yeah the only question was just
like how to properly balance that with
uh the the the rate of the story and
where we needed him to be by kind of the
climax by the end of it
um and it was fun I think we did like an
all right job at it I tried really hard
but otherwise it was just kind of left
between me and Maddie to kind of figure
it out on the day and play with each
other okay a question for both of you
now that I think could maybe tiptoe into
spoilers we'll try to not do that I feel
like it's a game it's kind of like a
puzzle how am I gonna figure this out
um given the evolution that your
characters go through did you hat and
like what they learn about themselves
what they learn about what's happening
around them did you have like a Guiding
Light of sorts where like no matter if a
decision is made out of fear or not
knowing or learning something new there
was some sort of like constant a thing
that kept them consistent from beginning
to end
I mean I mean do you for for me I feel
like I see purely for me on your face
right now because we talked about this
QA and when I gave Manny a compliment at
the Q a she gave me the finger I'm like
two two fingers and I but I'm gonna give
another one like the constant for me was
you know regardless of
how seamlessly and how good the crew was
and how great it was working with
Mercedes she's such an actor's director
um
it was just doing the scenes with you
like you were the constant like every no
matter what I was doing I always felt
like if I veered off course she was
gonna guide me right back and I tried to
do the same for her because she's the
coolest it's [ __ ] great that's it I
agree with that thanks for not giving me
the figure but that's it that's that's
it I'm fragile today I'll cry Atticus
don't I love you stop it put your love
away
um
what was the question a guiding life
some sort of Guiding Light or anchor to
have some sort of consistency for the
character as she learned and grew
throughout the course of the movie
um I think I drew on a lot of personal
experiences and I don't I don't really
remember that much from shooting this
because I
I like did this crazy weird thing that I
have never done and like I lost 30
pounds and I wasn't eating and I ran
like 10 miles a day and I was just like
in this wild
wild head space so I was just like kind
of
I was just kind of like going I wasn't I
wasn't thinking about how's this gonna
land or where does this fall in the
script or whereas I was just trusting
Mercedes I was trusting Atticus I was
trusting Genesis and just like just
trying to be
present and also not passed out
I I could feel a lot of what you were
describing in your profile I I seriously
like how do you look at a script like
this and say to yourself like I'm okay
putting myself through all this because
you literally do not get a moment in
this movie to kind of sit back and relax
you have to be at an 11 from start to
stop yeah I think there's something
wrong with me and I am talking to my my
therapist Leslie about it but I do like
sadness
in a hot way you know and like a fresh
flirty way you know what I mean I cut no
I kind of think that that might be a
good thing because if the picks are
moving so generous it's a Pixar movie
Inside Out taught me anything it's that
sadness is a very valuable emotion that
we need to we need to embrace and
balance with all the other ones that we
want we think we want to have more you
know what's also nice that I realized in
my daily life I don't really I I
intellectualize my feelings I don't like
dive into them and when I work it feels
like a really safe contained environment
to just be like really angry and really
sad and really and have them all out
there and it doesn't feel as safe to me
like in my personal life to feel those
not negative emotions but motions
emotions that just can feel like
consuming you know what I mean very much
get that almost like this movie about
reenactment therapy was its own version
of reenactment it was I worked some
stuff out yeah I worked some stuff out I
feel tricked yeah I feel like I need you
to build like an escape room version of
this so I can have some of that therapy
in my life as well we can do that for
you okay I'll sign up Mercedes yeah
let's go okay you already mentioned
feeling safe exploring and going to
those extremes in this environment for
for both of you what is something
Mercedes does as an actors director and
a leader on set to create that kind of
environment also what is something about
the way she works with actors that
you're really excited for more actors
out there to get to experience on her
future films
um the the the big thing that stood out
to me was just the the level of for such
a tight script and for something that is
so purposeful every single word we were
still allowed to just play and explore
and there's there's one scene that kind
of the I guess the climax of the movie
that we spent an entire day on and
I mean Maddie just like didn't talk to
each other outside of it but we were
just we were given take after take after
take after take to just explore every
single divot of this scene and and it
just it made me very happy you know
shooting this intensely emotional thing
and then we would wrap up and and look
over Mercedes just be like do we want to
do seven more let's do seven more just
just keep going give me whatever the
hell you want to give me and that was
just that's the best feeling I think as
as an actor to just work with somebody
who gives you that level of trust it's
it's beautiful yeah yes we trust Freedom
collaboration and one thing I really
liked that you did is you wouldn't come
up with like a specific note you'd just
be like okay let's do this now
you were like that was one way let's
let's try this yeah it wasn't like okay
but now I think now I think you should
do it was like do you want to try
something crazy yeah well we got
interesting things I never would have
expected like there's this one scene
that I remember it's like we did it all
the same ways for like five takes and
for the sixth take I was like Maddie try
like try making him think that you're
like seducing him yeah and it was just
like different than anything else in the
movie and you just like you went with it
and it was just like us trying something
and that's what we ended up using I
remember and you were like chug that
glass of champagne yeah what was it yeah
it was like chug it yeah I was like okay
yeah yeah it was fun can you paint a
little picture of what your set looked
like because I was reading the Press
notes and this sounds like a one of a
kind type of shooting environment it was
wild
um okay so I'm just gonna like try to
paint the picture as much as I can so
basically it was a six-story abandoned
hospital but it wasn't a hospital we
built our own hospital and it was just
this like gutted building there was a
morgue in the basement that we had to
walk through every single day to get to
set that was a morgue it was a morgue
cool now you know
um and at the beginning actually some of
our crew members thought it was haunted
so we had to have a Native American
Chieftain come before we started
shooting to like do like a four hour
cleansing ritual to make everyone feel
okay
um and so then what was also wild is
like our whole movie's custom built sets
that even like open off into this
wanted to be able to like flow through
them within our building we have shots
where like the camera drops down three
floors because we're like great there's
like a hole in this building that we can
just like drop our camera down because
that's where they used to drop the
bodies all the way down to the morgue
yeah it was like it was like a Batman
and Robin situation down the pole what
no
I don't know how morgs work
that is something else uh like
production wise and building the sets
and I guess some of the bigger set
pieces was there any particular one in
the shooting schedule that you kind of
circled and said that's going to be the
most ambitious one to pull off and then
was that indeed the case or did
something else Catch You by surprise I
think everything we did was kind of
intense so I feel like every day we're
like here we go
um but I think like the most one of the
most physically taxing things is we like
man-made Lakes inside of our buildings
so it's like the whole second floor we
like flooded and converted into a lake
and so it was really intense because
these guys had to be like running around
in it all day long along with our crews
we all had like boots on and it's like
near freezing weather it's like two
degrees above so you can even see our
actor's breath sometimes on screen which
we couldn't help because our building's
huge but like it kind of gives it The
Surreal feeling oh my yeah in a it
sounds to me like you need to have like
like a lot planned out to a T activity
it's just so like you have that
flexibility to play around on set but
was there ever a day where like things
were going so wrong that you thought you
weren't going to be able to find a
creative solution or recover but you
guys rallied and you figured out a way
to make something work yeah I mean I
think that's like that's the madness of
filmmaking right but I think it's like
having people you trust were like when
something like that happens we're like
okay we can't shoot in the dollhouse
right now we're like okay great go to
the lake
um and it's like everyone's so prepared
that we just know what we're gonna do
next so I feel like that happens so many
times but we were just always so like go
that I can't even recall like a specific
one it's fair enough yeah all I keep
thinking about and we can't really talk
about it is just that epic wonder you
have near the end of the movie I am just
so incredibly impressed by how damn good
that looks thank you yeah winners are
fun and that one's pretty Waggy it is
something else I feel like I have to let
you go so I have a million more
questions we always like squeezing in
some like future project questions and
I'm coming your way it's not something
that actually exists but I will promise
you that every time we talk until this
happens I will ask you this question I'm
malignant too we need it don't we what
is the next chapter of her story that
you would like to see I'm sure James
would do it he he loves malignant I'm
sure he'd do it I don't know I'm not in
charge you should be in charge
I think so too thank you for saying that
I feel like she should harness Gabriel's
Powers Yeah and be some sort of hero and
then you're the sidekick
the sidekick no that's badass that's
badass Robin
's not hot if you were her if you were
her sidekick
put like Batman Robin which one do you
want to be do you know what I mean I
mean Batman seems real stressed all the
time that's true you do get like the
good end of the stick Batman's got to do
most of the work and you're just gonna
be like hot and you get to make out with
Alicia Silverstone
I don't care who knows it I love the
George Clooney Batman so good I yeah so
cam it's so good I I love that movie but
in sleep boy Camp as a tiny child I had
a big gigantic Batman Forever poster
hanging above my bed and I thought I was
the coolest and still to this day I
think I was the coolest kid yeah
straight up best Batman I don't care
that's the hot takes that is a cold take
Val's Batman oh my God he's the only one
who got it
if you like Batman and Robin you should
also see Batman Forever see but I just
like movies that are shitty
what do you think anything
Batman Forever
what is what is your favorite movie of
all time or not even favorite movie of
all time but what is the movie that you
repeat watch the most I can't wait to
hear this answer
the holiday that is such a good romantic
comedy I could watch that over and over
I've seen it so many times that's a good
movie weirdly I've also seen Blackfish a
lot oh I can't watch that over and over
no I know a lot of people are like
that's so sad but it's like a comfort
watch to me
maybe a comfort watch in it being a good
movie but also it existing letting you
know that people out there are doing
something about it or be or raising
awareness about it I just like whales
I like whales too and I like all
Batman's my favorite movie yeah Comfort
movie
um favorite movie of all time in the
movie that I've watched the most is
Jurassic Park as both yeah whoa It's
either Jurassic Park or scream but I've
seen both an absurd amount of times I
already have a Jurassic Park tattoo I'm
getting a screen tattoo soon will be
great
all right now I'm getting yelled at I
have to let you guys go I can talk about
your movie and Batman's forever
congratulations thank you for coming by
to everybody out there keep an eye out
for fixation we will see you soon with
more Tiff 2022 interviews